[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL NASH: So I'm Paul Nash.
I'm the product lead
for Compute Engine.
And I have with me
today Michael Crandell,
CEO and founder of Rightscale.
He'll be up in a little bit.
So today we wanted to talk
about Google's approach
to cloud pricing in general, and
how we think about customers,
and what we try to optimize
for in building products.
And then, specifically
for Compute Engine,
we want to talk
about the customer
friendly pricing
features that we've
come up with that we think
are really a great way
to use the cloud.
Then we're going to talk
a little bit about how,
beyond that set of
features and discounts,
there are some other things you
can do to add to your workload
to save even more money.
And then finally,
we'll have Michael up
to show some real world examples
using customer data of what
that looks like on paper.
And then we'll take
your questions as well,
or you can all run
away and have beer.
I'm fine either way.
So Google's approach to cloud
starts with Google's approach
to customers, in general.
And one of the things that
I mean about that is we
have a set of core
values at Google
about key principles like data
security, privacy and above all
user trust.
So we believe that maintaining
our users and customers'
trust in Google is looking
out for their best interests
as one of our highest callings.
So additionally, our
goal is to build products
that are simple to
use and well-designed,
and this includes
how you pay for them.
So what that boils down to
in Compute Engine is really
three core pricing
philosophy principles that we
use to think about
how we're pricing
and how were building discounts.
The first is it
should be simple.
So no rocket science.
No PhDs in economics.
No ministries of pricing
within your companies as Urs
said this morning.
And no hidden costs.
Second, it should be flexible.
And what that means is
you pay for what you use.
Apparently, the whole point of
cloud is to be elastic, right?
Well, somethings are
more elastic than others.
And so for that to
be true the pricing
can't rope the developers
into a certain shape
of what you're using, or how
long you have to use it for,
or what you can do with it.
And finally, then, we
think the real embodiment
of user customer
trust is the idea
that prices should be fair.
So we should start with making
prices low, as low as we can.
And then, if we find ways
to bring additional savings
into the ecosystem, either
because we're scaling
or because we got
a better hardware,
or we found some new
efficiencies in how
our software is
managing that hardware,
you should get those savings
passed on to you as well.
And that includes also the
concept of automatic discounts.
So if you use the cloud in a way
that is more efficient for us,
we should pass those
savings on to you.
So what do I mean
when I say simplicity?
Well, this is a graphic that
one of our product managers
came up with.
It's a little
faded out, but this
is a screen capture
of our pricing page
sort of laid sideways, and one
of the other clouds pricing
pages laid sideways.
So it's a pretty
obvious representation
of how much do you have
to ingest and understand
in order to figure out what's
going on, how much am I paying.
I spend a lot of time
with these pages.
I'm sure some of
you have as well.
They are lovely pages.
But what I find is
that I also spend
a lot of time with Chrome's
search in page feature
to find where the
information is on that page
that I'm trying to understand
how much is a customer being
charged for that.
And it's not at all obvious that
that is a good use of my time.
In fact, usually I
don't consider it is.
I usually end up building
spreadsheets, in fact,
to break that information apart
and try to understand it more.
Wouldn't just be simpler if
you didn't have to do that,
and you can focus
on your application?
That's what we think about.
So one of the main ways that
pricing can get complicated
is in how various [? IS ?]
resources are bundled together
by some of the providers.
So this creates dozens
of different pre-canned
configurations--
I call it alphabet soup--
which are essentially
optimized for different classes
of workloads.
And the problem is,
as always, that that
requires a bunch
of generalizations
and a bunch of assumptions.
What if you need
all the RAM, but you
don't need all of the CPU?
Or what about that SSD that
you got for free in that VM?
Are you using that?
Because it's not free.
So understanding the
basic combinations
and all the sizes--
that can be kind
of a full time job.
And trying to figure out,
for example, simple things,
like how much are you
paying for one of the CPUs
in your machine, or
for a gigabyte of RAM,
it's hard to tell for sure.
And it's not always the same.
And what's worse,
every time they
add a new generation
of hardware,
you get a whole new set
of skews to figure out.
This is a problem we
talk about internally
called skew explosion.
So you have some giant page of
all the different price points
and how much everything costs.
And every time there's a new
discount model, or a new tweak,
or a new feature, you
get a whole another set
of those skews.
It's difficult to manage.
It's difficult to understand.
And so we try to
find a better way.
So by comparison, we have one
main family that's called N1.
There's a couple very special
machine types called F1 and G1.
But almost all of our usage,
and almost all of our customers
are using N1.
We might someday
have a second family,
but it's kind of a
big decision for us.
So we just have the one for now.
And what we try to do without is
give you a transparent pricing
performance.
So that allows us
to have as skews
as we possibly can to
understand in the first place.
The fewer things to
understand, the better.
And with something like
custom machine types
is actually only two.
There's how much a CPU costs,
and how much does RAM cost.
So that lets you buy
just what you need.
And you can use it
however you want,
either is one of our
predefined chips,
or as a custom machine type.
So with a custom machine types
and the predefined chips,
we put some predefineds
in there just so
that it would be a little
bit easier to get started.
So there's a couple
typical ratios of RAM
to CPU that a lot of
customers will find adequate
for most of their workloads.
But you should just think of
those little marks on the dials
that you can use to start.
If you want to start
there that's great.
If you don't, you can build
a custom machine type.
And either way if you
find later that you're not
using the right
amount of resources,
you can optimize that easily.
In fact we will
help you do that.
So a VM at its
essence, of course,
is just that CPU and RAM.
And anything else we
view is an add-on.
So another way that
we try to keep things
simple and transparent
is by trying
to not bundle in
the different pieces
together, and giving you
an opaque product that
hides the different costs
of those various components.
So why do the others
do it this way?
Well, it's easier.
But it's easier for
them, not for you.
So pre-configuring a hardware
according to a fixed recipe,
that would sure make it easier
for us to manage our fleet,
but it would make you
inherit the complexity.
So what would end
up happening is
that you'd pay the price
because you pay for things
you don't need.
And they'd all be
bundled together
in whatever alphabet
letter you decided
was the right VM
for your workload.
So we decided to keep
our prices visible
and let you choose
what you need.
And then we'll take care
of the fleet efficiency
behind the scenes
using Google magic.
So just to give you an example
of one of the things that
tends to get bundled in on
some clouds is how much does it
cost to run Windows on a VM?
Well, turns out you
can't really tell,
unless you go back
to that long page
and build a spreadsheet
and crack everything apart.
And once you do
that, what you'll see
is that, depending
on the alphabet
letter that you choose, the
cost of Windows per core
is different.
But that's kind of strange
because the costs for us
to sell you a Windows
license per core
doesn't change if we run it
on a faster or slower CPU,
or on one that has more RAM, or
memory, or disk attached to it.
So on Google Cloud,
it's always $0.04
per core per hour,
no matter what.
So now I want to talk
about flexibility.
And that really means
these two concepts.
So pay for what you use
and buy only what you need.
Sounds simple, right?
Everybody does it?
Not so much.
So everybody assumes that
cloud is pay as you use.
But it turns out that the
way that you count usage
matters a lot in practice.
So in GCU, we've had
permanent billing from day one
because at Google we
understand that workloads
don't come in our long
chunks most of the time.
So for example,
imagine that you had
a set of VMs illustrated
just below by this bar chart
that we're running for
different periods of time.
And there are a number of
ways this could happen.
One is that maybe they're part
of an auto scaled workload.
And some of them are only needed
for a small amount of time.
And some of them are
needed for most of the time
that you're
experiencing a spike.
Another way that
this may happen is
if you're doing some
batch processing
and there's a number of
different tasks being
distributed to VMs, then
you need some for a while,
and then others you
don't need for a while.
So moving rendering
might be a good example
of that where you
don't know what
the frame time is going to be.
Well, if on the left
you had 0 to 60 minutes,
and your workload takes
the amount of time in blue,
then all that stuff
in there is wasted.
And in this particular
hypothetical example,
that's like 40% of
what you're paying.
So this is a slightly
different scenario
that we model to illustrate
what would happen if you were
using an auto scaled workload.
So in this example,
the bar charts
are representing a
set of VMs you have
where every VM can run
20 queries per second.
And let's imagine that
this is a website,
and a talk show
host-- famous talk
show host-- has just mentioned
our website on live TV.
And we had this burst.
And everybody wants to
come and buy our widget.
So in order to
react to that scale
you're going to spin up
something like 50 VMs.
But here's the thing--
when you go to spin those
down, whether you spin them
down right away or not,
if you're paying per hour,
you're still paying for another
chunk of usage that's almost as
big as a spike itself.
In fact, it looks a
little bit bigger.
If you pay per minute, it's
scaled down much faster
as the traffic dies away.
And this graph doesn't have
to be blocky like it is here.
This is just shown at
five minute intervals
to give you an idea of
what the steps look like.
But in reality, our
auto scaler at least
resamples every 60 seconds.
So it would follow that
curve much more smoothly.
So finally, another
use case we see a lot--
so imagine that you
have a workload that
takes about four hours to run,
and it runs on a four core
machine currently.
Now, let's say you go and do
a bunch of optimization work.
And you've got it
to the point where
you can scale up that workload.
And you're getting about
a 1.8x scaling factor--
could be 100, but
it's not every 2.0.
If you wanted double
the number of cores,
you're not going to
usually get exact scaling.
So let's say that you get 1.8x.
So the graph on the left shows
what the run times would change
and how they would
change if you went
to 8 core, 16 cores,
or 32 core machine
under those assumptions.
And the graph on
the right shows what
you would pay if you were paying
per minute versus per hour.
So what happens is
the workload runtime
might fall below one
of the hour marks,
but you're still paying
for the extra waste.
And so all of your
work-- you might
have gotten your answer faster,
but you're paying more for it
too.
So this is one of
the key principles
that we believe is important
in a truly elastic cloud.
So next I want to
talk about VM sizes.
So why is it that machines are
sized in powers of two anyway?
Any of you know?
Have an idea?
I'll tell you why.
It's easier.
Again, though, it's easier for
whoever's building the cloud,
not for you, the customer.
So the computer scientists in
the room might recognize this.
It's called a bin
packing problem.
And if you don't
have powers of two,
the concern is that
it's harder to make sure
that all the
processors on a machine
are filled and then used
all the time without leaving
some behind.
Well, it turns out at Google we
solved that problem a long time
ago because we built our
cloud 10 to 15 years ago,
and we have lots
of workloads too,
but we need to pack them all
inefficiently on processors.
And so we built a system
called Borg that does that.
It further turns
out that when we
went to go build
our public cloud,
we built it all on that
same Borg technology.
So underneath Google
Compute Engine
is years of work from hundreds
of engineers figuring out
how to solve that problem
without making you just pay
for the inefficiency.
So if I sell you power
of two size machines,
like a 64 core machine, but you
actually only need 40 cores,
the other 24 cores are wasted.
If I'm the cloud
provider doing that,
I might not be
concerned about it
because you're paying for it.
If I'm Google and I'm building
that cloud for myself,
I'm concerned about it a lot
because I'm paying for it.
And it's a massive
amount of inefficiency.
So we get rid of all
that by offering you
custom machine types
which are built
on that same infrastructure.
Another advantage that
we've seen from this
is that a lot of
customers over time
have purchased specific
sized hardware.
And in an on premise fleet
it's common to see something
like a 12 core machine that's
actually 12 physical cores.
So if they want to move
that to the cloud today,
they'd have to buy a 16
core VM in a lot of places.
And that automatically
shifts the bill
and makes the comparison
of costs difficult.
So if you have something
like custom machine types,
it's fine for a customer to
bring their building materials,
their whole list of all the
different VM sizes and shapes
that they have on prem today.
If they're thinking about
lifting and shifting
a workload, you can simply
configure a custom machine
type that matches those sizes,
bring all your workload in,
and then optimize when
it's convenient for you.
So we see customers do
that a lot to get a better
match between what they're
going to use in cloud,
and what they're using
today on premise.
In fact, we launched
this feature out
just a little over a year ago.
And in that time it's
grown to be about 20%
of our total usage by
core hours and in GCE.
And we went and
calculated the savings
from what customers
would have had
to spend if they were using
the next up standard size,
and it turns out
those customers that
are using it are saving
about 19% on average
simply by not overbuying.
So finally, I want to
talk about fairness.
So one of the
things we talk a lot
about with discounts is the
number, what's the percentage?
And there's a bunch of
numbers flying around.
Some are larger;
some are smaller.
One of the things I want
to take a minute to stress
is that the discount is only
one part of the equation.
Don't be fooled by
a larger number.
I'm sure we've all seen
the commercials where
there's 20% off the sofa.
But if the sofa was marked
up 4000% in the first place,
you might be better
off with the guy
down the street that's
offering a low everyday price.
So it's a little bit like that.
You need to look at factors
like, what's the list price?
What kind of flexibility are you
giving up to get the discounts?
What kind of
strings or attached?
And are you paying
for hidden things
that you don't actually need?
And more often than
not what we find
is when people do that
whole calculation,
Google comes out ahead in terms
of what you save by default,
and what you can save by
making optimizations to usage.
So in 2014, when we launched
Google Cloud Platform,
we introduced a new way to
bring discounts to customers.
And we think it's a better way.
So when you use our
VMs consistently,
it's more efficient for us.
And we think our
principle of fairness
means that when we save
money because you're
using our cloud in a way
that's more efficient for us,
you deserve to get that back.
So that's what's Sustained
Use Discounts to you.
And the nice thing about
that is that you still
maintain all the flexibility
of an on demand cloud.
And you can start and stop your
instances whenever you want.
You can change
your usage pattern.
It's all up to you.
And we'll just give
you the best discount
that your usage qualifies
for automatically
on a month by month basis.
So one detail I
want to mention here
is that there's actually
two modes of calculation
for Sustained Use Discount.
If you want, you can call
them SUD 1.0 and SUD 2.0.
The first this is the original
Sustained Used Discount
that we launched, which
uses a concept called
inferred instances.
And I want to talk about what
that is in just a minute.
The second is what we do
with custom machine types.
So when we launched
custom machine types,
the concept of
inferred instances
got a little complicated because
with custom machine types
you can essentially have
thousands of different shapes
of machines.
And so what inferred
instances does
is it combines together
usage of same shape.
But now with custom
machine types
you won't have same shapes.
So what we do instead is we
look at the total chunk of CPUs
and RAM that you use
throughout the month,
and we give you a similar
discount for sustained usage.
So just briefly, what
is an inferred instance?
This is something we
sometimes get questions about,
so I wanted to explain
a little bit more.
So in this graphic, imagine that
you're using some 1 core VMs,
and you use five
different instances
at various times
in the month as is
represented on the left
side in the left crash.
So you use instance 1
for about half the month.
Sometime about the tenth of
the month you start instance 2.
And then about halfway
through the month
you start 3, and 4 and 5.
So on the surface of
it if you understand
that Sustained Use Discounts--
the whole point is we give you
more discount for the more you
use it throughout the month.
It doesn't necessarily
look like you
would get a whole
ton of discount
because none of those instances
are being used for very
much in the month at all.
They would get the first
tier for 25% usage,
but maybe not much more.
So we didn't think that was
necessarily fair because it
doesn't matter much
to our efficiency
if you run one instance
here, and then shut it down
for a while, and then
run another instance
the next day that's
exactly the same shape,
and run that for the
rest of the month.
So what we do is we
re-imagine your usage pattern.
We reinterpret it to look
like the grass in the middle.
So you can see we flip
the number 3 VM down.
And this is just conceptual.
This is a big data
processing problem
that our billing system
does automatically for you.
But conceptually,
we've taken VM number 3
and flipped it down as
if it were part of VM 1.
And then we've aligned
VMs 2 and 4 and part of 5
as if they were a second VM.
And then we've left the rest
of 5 as if it was a third VM.
So now this graph
on the right is what
we compute your discount on.
And it's a much bigger discount
than you would have gotten
in the graph in the left.
So you can see that
it looks like you
used one inferred instance
for the entire month.
And then the second instance
you used for over half a month.
And then the third instance
you used for about a quarter
of the month.
So each of those will get
a different tier of SUD.
But it will be a
much higher tier
than you would have gotten
in combination on the left.
So this is one of the
ways that we calculate
what's the best deal for you.
So we've had Sustained Used
Discounts in production
for a few years now.
And customers really liked them.
And they're getting a lot
of savings out of them.
But some of the
conversations we've had
is, is there any way you can
give me a better discount?
Sustained Used Discount,
it resets every month.
But many customers
say to us, hey,
I know that I'm going to use
a certain amount of resources
100% of the time
to run my website.
And that's just getting
bigger every month.
So is there some way that you
can give me a better discount
if I tell you how
much I'm going to use
at a minimum for the whole
year, or maybe longer?
So that brings us to
the question of product
we announced this morning
called Committed Use Discounts.
So basically the premise of
the product is if you knew
and you could tell
Google that you
were going to use a certain
minimum amount of resources
all year, shouldn't you
get a bigger discount?
And there's one obvious
answer to that-- we say yes.
So how does it work?
Basically we give you the best
discounts we possibly can.
If you agree to buy resources
for one year or for three.
But don't worry, we don't
require any large upfront
payments.
You can pay us monthly
and that's cool.
We've got $30 billion we're
spending on infrastructure.
And we don't need to
charge you all up front.
Your promise is
good enough for us.
So what we do with that, though,
is give you all the flexibility
so that you can make
changes whenever you want.
If you decide one
day that you're
going to go into
your application code
and optimize it, and all
of a sudden you find a bug,
and it turns out that you
need 50% less compute than you
thought you did, awesome.
Change the instance sizes.
Keep on going.
And you'll still
get your discount.
Additionally, we don't
charge you any discount
to get that flexibility.
So some competing
products, if you
want to be able to
convert them, you
will lose some of the discount.
You'll not get the
maximum discount.
And that's not how ours works.
So how much?
So for predefined machine
types, you'll get 37% off
for a one year discount--
for one year commitment.
And for three years
you'll get 55%.
And these numbers are
actually a little bit higher
for a custom machine
type, they're 40 and 57,
respectively.
So the way that we
make that flexible
is that the whole
thing is designed based
on the underlying resources.
So if you think
back a minute ago,
when I was talking about
Sustained Use Discounts,
and how SUD 2.0 looks at
the number of cores and RAM
that you've used, Committed
Use Discounts are the same way.
So rather than trying to predict
how many machines you need
of a certain size in what
zone, just tell us how much CPU
and how much RAM,
and then you can
use those in any combination.
So it sounds like we're
asking you to tell us more,
but it's actually simpler
because most customers already
know that math.
Additionally then,
like I said, they're
not tied to any
particular VM shape.
But they're also not tied to any
particular VM instance itself.
So what we do is we simply
look at how much was running
at every moment in time--
every minute-- and we take
the first chunk of that,
and we give you a Committed
Use Discount on it.
But the thing then is,
whatever's above that,
we still give you permanent
billing and Sustained Use
Discount on all the rest.
So there's no penalty to having
a Committed Use Discount as
long as that is the
minimum that you're
going to be using
because you're still
going to get the full
discounts on all the rest.
So if you're not sure how
much to buy, start small.
See how your
workload is running.
And then you can increase
over time if you need to.
And you can know
that you're still
getting a really competitive
discount on the rest of it.
So I'll give us a
little example just
to show you what
that looks like.
Very simply in this
picture, if you
imagine that there
is a threshold where
you have a certain
amount of committed use,
and then above that you're
getting sustained use,
you can see where VM A
is shut down for a while
and then comes back.
But what we've done is said, OK,
well, for that period of time,
the usage from VM E
gets committed use.
And then later it'll
get sustained use again.
And obviously this is going
to look like a much more
complex picture in reality.
So finally, I want to
talk about some tuning--
some features you can
use to take advantage
of tuning your workload so that
it's best configured to get
the maximum savings on GCE.
So the first feature
is rightsizing.
And you've probably seen this.
We talked about it in a
couple of different places.
The social media had
a kind of common idea
when we introduced
this features.
What are they, crazy?
They're telling me how to
spend less money on purpose?
Yes, we are.
So we would rather that you
optimize your infrastructure
usage for what your
workload actually needs,
rather than trying to
optimize your workload
to fit in particular sized
infrastructure of ours.
And we would rather that you
buy what's valuable to you
and nothing more.
We'll happily sell the rest
of that to somebody else.
So what this does
is automatically
monitors your CPU and RAM
usage from outside the VM.
And if it sees that you never
use more than a certain amount
of CPU, we'll recommend
that you scale down the CPU.
If you're never using more
than a certain amount of RAM,
it'll scale that down too.
And turns out is one
additional detail of this,
if you actually install this
Stackdriver monitoring agent,
then we get better
memory information,
and we can actually make a
better recommendation for you.
But either way, you'll
get a good recommendation
on what kind of
machine you want.
And then, simply, all
you need to do there
is on the right hand side.
Click that recommendation,
and you can--
you need to shut down and
quickly restart your VM
in order to change the size.
It's just that simple.
Finally, I also want to
talk about preemptible VMs.
So the idea with
preemptible VMs is
to offer a product that is
as low cost as we can make it
and optimized for
short term workloads.
So if you have a large
scale fault tolerant
workload that can withstand
a few of its workers
shutting down without losing
too much of your overall work,
then that's probably a job
that is really ideal for permit
preemptable VMs
And if you use those, you'll
find that there are almost 80%
off of list prices.
In some cases, they are 80%.
In some cases, they're
a little bit less.
The only restrictions are that
there's a maximum lifetime
on that VM of 24 hours.
And there's a small
probability chance
that we might take
back the VM early.
We'll give you a short
warning of about 30 seconds
and say, hey, we need that back.
So a lot of workloads-- and you
can see there's a whole list
of different ones below--
are finding that that's
a really efficient way
to get large amounts of compute.
So one of my colleagues
in a room down the hall
right now is talking
about an example
where Fermilab ran 160,000
cores preemptible in order
to calculate higher energy
physics experiments.
And he actually doubled the
compute fleet of Fermi National
Accelerator Laboratory in
finding exotic new physics
particles.
So it's just one
example of what you
can do with preemptible VMs
in a very affordable way.
But there's lots of other use
cases from genomics and genome
sequencing to computational
chemistry fluid dynamics etc.
So finally, I want to
talk a little bit more
about our autoscaler.
I showed the graph earlier
that talked about how
permanent billing helps.
But there's actually some other
features of our autoscaler
that help save money too.
So first of all, the
fact that it's extremely
fast and reactive to workloads.
So unlike some
other autoscalers,
we've actually never
had to consider
building a feature where
you would either schedule
in advance for it to
scale up, or pre-warm VMs
so it could react faster.
We kind of feel like that's not
what auto is supposed to mean.
So ours just scales.
And because our VMs can do
it in 30 seconds or less,
we can actually react to
spikes very quickly, up
to millions of QPIs.
And what that means
is you don't have
to have VM sitting around
waiting or running longer
in case the spike comes back.
You don't have to have
them running just in case
there is a spike
because you never
know what might happen
in social media.
You don't have to worry
about any of that.
And all of those
VMs that might be
running handle
scenarios like that
are just money you're wasting.
So just the fact
that our autoscaler
works like this actually
saves you money as well.
And you might even
actually consider
whether workloads you might
not think are web server.
For example, those
workloads might
benefit from a fast autoscaler
and help you automatically
tune what you're using.
So that's a number of different
pricing features and discounts
that are available on GCE.
And now I'd like to invite
Michael Crandell, the CEO
and founder of RightScale up
to show you what some of that
looks like in practice.
Michael.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL CRANDELL:
Thanks very much, Paul.
You know, I wanted to start
out by sharing it's pleasure
to be here.
It's especially exciting
during this week of pretty
actually groundbreaking
announcements about pricing,
and innovative announcements.
And I just wanted to share that
maybe for those of you here
and those online
it's those of you who
are-- it's late on a Thursday.
It may be that
savings in cloud spend
is not the most exciting thing.
But I can share with you that
I guarantee the more you use
cloud-- and we hear
this all the time--
pretty soon as you start
getting those bills,
savings becomes a
lot more interesting
in your organization.
And so I promise that this is
going to be meaningful stuff.
A little background about us.
At Rightscale we focus
on cloud management.
And ever since about
five years ago we
acquired a small startup that
was focusing on a piece called
Cloud Cost Management,
Cloud Cost Analytics,
we've seen increasing interest
in both the opportunity
that can be achieved through
savings and the challenge.
And so let's dive right
in on the challenge side.
We also run every year a
State Of The Cloud survey.
We get about 1,000
responses from companies
ranging from small businesses
to enterprise level companies.
And we ask a bunch of questions.
And we ask one about waste.
What do you think you're
wasting in your cloud spend?
I think Hertzel shared that
this morning, this stat.
But the self-reported
waste, in other words,
the waste that people think
that's occurring is about 30%.
We've found from our product
and in close engagements
with customers that often is
upwards of 40, up toward 45%.
So it's pretty clear--
everyone agrees--
there is a lot of
waste, and that also
means there's a
lot of opportunity.
So I wanted to
share with you today
from Rightscale's perspective
in the field three
of the biggest areas that we
see that are waste out there,
and that are also
opportunities for savings.
And they focus around
these three areas.
One is not taking advantage of
discounts, discount structures
that are available.
The second is running
workloads that
don't need to run all the time,
and still running them 24/7.
And the last area is
over provisioning, right?
Underutilized instances and
VMs that are running out there.
And so we'd like to focus
across these three areas
on three of the
feature offerings
that you've heard about
today-- some of them
brand new offerings, committed
use and sustained use
discounts, preemptibles,
and custom machine types.
So let's launch in,
first on the first use
case, which is
optimizing and taking
full advantage of discounts.
Starting point there, most
of us are familiar with
what's probably the oldest and
most familiar discount scheme
out there-- it's from
Amazon Web Services--
called reserved instances.
And many of you may be familiar,
but just a quick refresher,
there are many types of these.
But to start with standard
reserved instances,
you're basically, in
order to get a discount,
you pick a specific size of
instance in a specific instance
family in a particular
region, and commit
to either a year or three
years to gain that discount.
And they also have a family
of RIs called convertible RIs.
And it's important to note
the discount is lower there,
and it's only available with
a three year commitment.
So what we find among
customers in this RI world
is actually a lot of resistance.
People struggle with this.
And the reason they struggle
with it is pretty simple.
It's because they're being
asked to predict the future.
And quite often the workloads
that they're dealing with,
the apps that
they're dealing with,
and the approaches they're
taking to development test
and production in the cloud
aren't that predictable.
And so you see some of
the reasons listed here.
I'm not sure if I might
change architectures.
We're not sure what might happen
to the utilization of our app.
There may be new
types of instances
coming with bigger discounts.
So there's fear of making a
commitment that you're not
going to fully use.
And there there's a
lack of flexibility
that causes hesitation.
So the reality is,
really, that in many apps
and many, many workloads
you're actually
dealing with constant change.
The approach to development and
test et cetera, is evolving.
Your architecture is
changing and evolving.
You're not sure what
your needs will be.
And we've often asked
ourselves, wouldn't it
be great if we could
get the discount,
but not be locked into
the specific instance
size commitments?
And here's an example of that.
It's just a hypothetical
example of--
I think it's five
instances on the left.
Maybe in the future
what you're using now
needs to change to
that 8 instance model
where, in this case, you're
using smaller instances
and distributing
the workload more.
Wouldn't it be great
if you could get that?
Well, actually, this is
just another description
of what's been announced
this week with Committed Use
Discount.
And again, you can get some
of that with convertible RIs,
but you're committed to three
years, which in our experience
is really quite a long time
frame for most customers.
Let's take a look at
a specific example.
This is an anonymised real
customer usage with cost
on the vertical and, over
time, on the horizontal.
And you can see that there is a
pretty steady base usage there
that's growing slightly.
And then during weekdays
some transient usage.
That's dev in test
in this example.
So if we map this to both
providers comparing AWS
and Google, on the AWS side
what we would recommend--
and we happen to know this
customer is using about 80%
of those instances--
are production, and about
50% for dev in test.
We would recommend if they're
having to lock in and commit
to standard RIs, we'd
say, why don't you
limit your exposure
there to 65% in order
to gain savings, but leave
yourself some flexibility
for change?
If you're going to commit
to convertible RIs,
go ahead and go up to 90%.
So that's what our
recommendation would typically
be over a long experience
helping customers save money.
Take a look at that on Google.
With Google pricing,
it's pretty much
a no brainer with the new
Committed Use Discount.
Just go ahead and
take 90% of it.
And buy into that with
a committed use discount
because there's no
flexibility trade-off.
And let the Sustained
Use Discount
with the inferred
instance capability
that Paul mentioned earlier
take care of the rest.
That's going to automatically
fit the pieces together
of the transient users into
the most optimal cost savings
for you.
If we map that on to actual
dollars, what you see here--
we've done the calcs for you.
I'm not going to go
through every detail there.
But we did map out
three different levels
with the assumptions that I
mentioned about 50% and 80%
averaging out.
So a standard RI, one year
reserved instance approach.
On the right hand
side, you can see
you're getting 21% savings
by using that mechanism.
Three year standard RI, 39%.
And the more comparable three
year convertible RI is 34%.
So what we're going
to look at here
to keep it apples to
apples and try and match
some of the flexibility in
the Google pricing scheme
that allows you to shift
instance sizes and families,
and so on, we're going to
map the first one, which
is that one year, and
the third one, which
is a three year convertible.
Here's what that
looks like on Google.
35% on the one year, which
represents 28% better
savings than the AWS
one year standard RI
approach in this example.
And then on three
year, 52% savings,
which represents a 35%
improvement over AWS three year
convertibles.
If you summarize all of
that into a single chart,
here's what you're looking at.
On one year, you
have better pricing.
On three year, you
have better pricing
than both the full three
year without convertible
and a three year
with convertible.
And other important
points to remember
is that on the one
year you still--
with committed use you
still get flexibility.
So that's an advantage
on flexibility,
whether it's one
year or three year.
You also get more ease of use.
Because it is
important to remember
with the convertible
RIs on AWS, you still
need to track your usage,
and make a special request
to AWS to sign in instance
to the convertible RI you've
bought.
In the Google scheme, that
happens automatically.
And then, of course, the
final and Third Point
is it's just less expensive.
So we think that's pretty
groundbreaking and pretty
compelling.
Second use case was
dev in test workloads.
So this is a starting point.
We are talking
about savings here.
And this doesn't really apply
to one cloud or another.
This applies to any
cloud that you run on.
And actually, I'll
admit might be
obvious to you-- it was a little
bit of a eye opener for me
years ago when I first
looked at it-- if you limit
your usage on your workload
to only say, 12 hours a day,
five days a week you're
actually saving 65%.
And that's a key thing that we
help people with automation.
And the rest of the
right scale platform
is to schedule run times
that don't run 24/7
when they don't need to.
Paul mentioned a whole
bunch of workloads.
I think one of the most
common is dev in test
that we're talking about here.
So when we map that to
the preemptible model
that Paul talked about,
we've got four levels there.
If you run with sustained
only, you see the first price,
around 67,000.
If you commit to
a portion of that,
you can achieve a 9% savings
with the Committed Use
Discount.
If you start mixing
committed with preempibles,
and if you can have a
dev in test workflow
that is tolerant of
instances being taken away--
and maybe it's just the loss
of a little time for you
versus loss of any data
if your dev task flow
allows for that, which means--
think about that.
That's a good thing.
You could save 40% by
splitting half and half.
And if you're able to put
all of that dev in test
on to preemptibles,
it's a 70% savings.
So there is an analog here with
Amazon's spot instance market,
difference being that in
that market it is a market
and you need to bid.
And so you're not
guaranteed a price.
You can get pretty
great savings.
But here you're
guaranteed a price.
You know what you'll be
paying in this model.
The last use case
I wanted to share
was around rightsizing
using custom machine types.
This is a screen shot of a
part of right scale on cost
analytics that we call
the utilization report.
And what you see here
along the horizontal axis
is how much memory utilization
there is on an instance.
So farther to the
right, more memory.
Farther up vertically on the
graph, more CPU utilization.
The instances or VMs are
represented by the circles.
And the size of the
circle is the cost
that you're paying for that VM.
So immediately
with a single blink
your eye can go to
the lower left and go,
I'm paying for stuff
that I'm not using there.
And that's pretty great
to be able to see.
Now, sometimes
that's on purpose.
For example, you might have
a warm spare, hot spare
sitting there for some sort
of disaster recovery scenario.
So it might be on purpose.
But in many cases it's not.
And when we work
with customers we
say in that very
lower left, that's
a candidate for
downsizing a t-shirt size
or two with the standard
predefined VMs types.
But more importantly, when we're
talking about custom machine
types in the upper left,
that's an example of VMs
where the CPU utilization
is pretty reasonably high,
but not the memory.
So you might want to dial in
a custom machine type that
lowered the memory requirement.
Same applies in the lower right,
just the converse-- high memory
utilization, low CPU.
So here's another example.
Let's say you need it four CPUs
and 20 gigs in a machine size.
Standard predefined VMs
on both AWS and Google,
you'd have to get an
eight CPU and 30 gigabyte.
And you can see what
the pricing is there.
And I think that
Google pricing is
updated for the
announcements this week.
But if you're able to dial in
a custom VM in this example,
you save even more.
You're able to save 42% over
the standard predefined size
on Google, and 64% over the
standard predefined size
on AWS.
So that's a quick tour of these
three approaches to savings.
And I think the bottom line
is that with the announcements
you've heard this week, as well
as other mechanisms Google's
had in place for
pricing, they've
pretty much upped the ante and
taken the lead in the cloud
provider space for offering
very customer friendly pricing.
So I would just say compliments
to the whole Google Cloud team.
We're very impressed with that.
And thank you for making all of
this a whole lot easier for us
customers out there.
By the way, if you're interested
in learning more about
Rightscale-- and Paul, why don't
you start coming back up here
too because we'll do some Q&A--
we do have a booth
here downstairs.
We also are doing a webinar,
I think, the two of us
together later this month with
a deeper dive on March 23rd.
You can also get that
State Of The Cloud
report that I referred to
earlier off of our website.